starting today we are having a 10 back
to school sale over at microcosmos dot
store so whether you are decorating a
new dorm room or a classroom or you're
just trying to decide what to wear on
your first day of school micro cosmos
dot store has you covered we've got
t-shirts sweatshirts pins posters and
we've got our micro cosmos microscope
slides and cover slips and even a micro
cosmos microfiber cloth to keep
everything nice and clean and this week
only from now through august 8th almost
everything in the store is 10 off that's
not all though we've also got this new
dark mode version of our hydra t-shirt
that's only going to be available during
this sale and then never again so head
to microcosmos.store to check out the
sale and to pick up your limited edition
dark mode hydra shirt
[Music]
[Music]
this channel would not be what it is if
it weren't for one very key invention
the microscope
everything we see we see with the aid of
light and lenses expertly deployed by
our master of microscopes james and if
you've been on this journey from the
beginning or if you've ever gone back to
revisit our earlier videos you may have
noticed that things have changed a bit
around here everything we can see is a
function of the tools we use and as we
explore new microscopes along with other
new tools and techniques that means
we've been able to see the microcosmos
differently colors have changed contrast
has deepened and sometimes
things even sparkle
so today we are tracking our journey
through
our journey we have compiled the videos
we have made that focus on how our
microscopes work and the ways we have
improved our methods over time so you
can see how much of microscopy is an art
an art that uses light in incredible
ways that only physics could predict
so to start let's go back to an early
video where we went through the
different methods we used at the start
of our channel to illuminate our samples
think of it like an introduction to
optics told through the bodies of
tardigrades and algae
[Music]
this is a ciliate just a eukaryotic
microbe waving its cilia around under
our microscope
and this is the same ciliate
and yep here it is again and again but
as you're probably noticing while the
rough outline of this organism seems the
same from shot to shot the ciliate
itself and the world around it clearly
look
very different
colors change details are more apparent
in one case the organism seems to be lit
from within
on this channel we're constantly
flipping between different ways of
capturing images of organisms
so which one of them is what they
actually look like
well
none of them
[Music]
anything you see through a microscope is
an image which in our case means that
everything we show you on this channel
every frame
is not the microbial world itself it's
an interpretation of the life on the
other side of our objective
translated through the lens into details
and shapes and colors all affected by
the way we light up the life we want to
see
light is amazing it's also very weird it
travels in waves and as it interacts
with particles and materials it scatters
and shifts
even if we can't actually see those
light waves in motion
so much of what we observe in the world
around us is rooted in the physical
properties that define those waves like
how we can observe certain frequencies
of light as colors but waves
have far more to them than just their
frequency and microscopy has combined
the resourcefulness of many different
sciences to use light to give us
different ways to peer into the
microbial world
so let's start simple good old-fashioned
white light early microscopists used oil
lamps and sunlight to see through their
microscopes and while the technology has
changed the simplicity of this has
endured into the modern technique of
bright field microscopy it all starts
with a source of light though modern
microscopes have their lamps built in
set up underneath the stage that holds
our sample
light travels from the source through a
condenser which works to focus the light
onto the sample above it this focused
light travels through the sample towards
the objective lens which takes in an
image and magnifies it into these bright
backgrounds with organisms sometimes
rendered transparent by the intensity of
the light you might say that this is as
close as we get to seeing what the
microcosmos actually looks like but that
would be like taking a 2 000 watt light
bulb into your living room and saying
this is what my home looks like light
affects things and we're not even
shining light on these organisms we're
shining light through them now
brightfield might seem relatively simple
but that simplicity has been incredibly
powerful in allowing scientists old and
new to wade through microscopic waters
still
there are limitations to consider with
any scientific technique and one of the
major challenges for bright field
microscopy particularly when looking at
microbes is contrast
pigmented organisms are easy to
visualize against the bright background
but in cases where the organism has been
rendered transparent it can be harder to
distinguish their bodies from the rest
of the world they inhabit
scientists can navigate these challenges
using stains that make certain
structures more visible but for our
purposes we like to avoid stains because
they can affect the microbes themselves
there are other ways though to content
with this challenge
one of which is built on one of those
simple yet strange properties of our
world you don't always need to shine
light directly onto an object to see it
this technique is called dark field
microscopy which sounds like it must be
almost the opposite of bright field
microscopy
it's not the two techniques are actually
very similar
light travels from a source through a
condenser goes through the sample and
then it travels into the objective lens
producing the image we see but what we
want in dark field microscopy is for the
beam of light
to hit the sample
but not our eye
so in dark field microscopy a circular
disk is placed inside the condenser
blocking the central part of the light
from shining through the sample and into
our eye or our camera
this means that when there is no sample
on the slide all you see is black
but the disc doesn't block all of the
light
there's still a hollow cone of light
that travels around the disk unable to
reach the objective or our eyes but that
still hits the sample
when it does those microscopic
transparent bodies scatter those hidden
rays into our view and as they do an
image of their bodies forms against a
dark background providing us with this
almost cinematic footage
another method to get better contrast
than brightfield microscopy is called
phase contrast microscopy and it's built
on working with a property of light that
we can't actually directly experience
microbes or really anything that is
easily visually observed with bright
field microscopy are called amplitude
objects because as light passes through
them the amplitude of the light wave
changes which we see as changes in light
intensity but there is another class of
specimens these are called phase objects
as light passes through these objects
the waves slow down and shift slightly
in phase compared to the unaffected
light around it and if you're wondering
what that means in terms of what we can
see that's the issue
our eyes don't process these differences
in phase
and so in the final image these objects
or in our case organisms are very
difficult to see
[Music]
well in the 1930s a physicist named
fritz zarnica developed a method to
shift the direct light just slightly
enough so that these changes in phase
could actually be translated into
changes in amplitude
producing an image of these formerly
hard to see phase objects by essentially
treating them as amplitude objects
there's a lot of physics in this that
we're not going to get into but the
result was so important that it would
eventually win zarnica the nobel prize
in physics and of course selfishly we
here appreciate his work because it lets
us see more of our hidden microbial
friends
and for the last type of microscopy
we'll go over today we're going to be
getting into another property of light
that we can't directly see
and this one
can make the microcosmos glow
most of the light we see has an
electrical field that vibrates in all
sorts of planes relative to the
direction the light is traveling in
but that vibration can be restricted to
just one plane and when that happens the
light is said to be polarized
we can't see the difference between
polarized and unpolarized light now you
might see the difference in how the
world looks when you're wearing
polarized sunglasses but these changes
are brought about by changes in color or
intensity not the polarization of the
light itself
so when does polarized light help
microscopy well a lot of materials stay
the same optically speaking no matter
what direction you shoot light at them
from but there are certain materials
where specific properties like how fast
light travels through them can vary
depending on which way the light is
striking them
these materials called optically
anisotropic
can also take in a ray of light and
divide it into two separate beams
by aiming polarized light at our sample
and then reconstructing an image based
on how the various parts of the organism
interacts with that restricted light
particularly by how it might cause that
light to split we can see more of these
optically anisotropic materials in
action in our case it often takes the
form of shiny internal crystals
[Music]
so
we've given you the big overview of what
these different techniques can do let's
go back and look at what that means for
that original ciliate we started with
here it is under bright field microscopy
the background is bright the image
produced by changes in light amplitude
that allow us to see the overall shape
but some of the detail is hard to make
out
under dark field though the contrast
increases and some of those details
become more obvious displaying
compartments and cilia in greater detail
that are also apparent under phase
contrast
and then under polarized light the
crystals that blended in with the
organism previously are now
visible and vibrant
now of course there are many other
microscopy techniques that use light in
many different ways but we think it's
incredible that with just these four
the world of the microcosmos looks
almost like different universes wrapped
up into one invisible world around us
the journey it seems is not just about
what you see
but also
how you see it
and ultimately
none of these views are what the
microcosmos actually looks like either
that or
all of them are
our brains play tricks on us to make us
believe that the world looks one way
but the world looks different at night
than in the day
and both of those things have more to do
with the physiology of our eyes and our
brains than with objective reality
asking what a microbe actually looks
like is to some extent forcing our own
experience onto something that is
beyond it which is not something i ever
would have thought of if it weren't for
this little youtube channel
now we have been very fortunate over the
years to have had the support of so many
people and to be able to direct that
support back to the microscopes we use
in 2020 we introduced james's new
microscope which he was able to buy
thanks to crowdfunding this was our
first major microscope upgrade on the
series and it's incredible to see the
jump in quality and how it compares to
the different techniques we showcased in
the previous video
this golden algae is swimming around in
water and white light illuminated from
below using a bright field microscope
and here
we have that malamuna sample filmed a
day later using a different technique
thanks to a brand new
freshly installed microscope when james
our master of microscopes saw them for
the first time he got a little emotional
because to quote him directly the thing
i know so well was looking
so
so much different than usual
[Music]
those differences in how the malamonas
look are due to a type of microscopy
called differential interference
contrast or dic
earlier this year
james started a crowdfunding campaign to
purchase a new microscope one that would
allow him to use differential
interference contrast to produce these
images you are seeing now
now technically differential
interference contrast
is not a type of microscope rather it's
a method
that enhances
contrast and as you can see
the final product is an image that seems
almost three dimensional
just watch this stenter corulius as it
swims across the slide its cilia are so
prominent that it almost
feels like you can
touch their vibrating fuzziness and the
striations down its body are so sharp
that when the center contracts it's like
you can feel it pushing inward and then
back out
again differential interference contrast
microscopy was invented by georges
nomarski in 1952
building off the principle's underlying
phase contrast microscopy which is a
different though similar thing but both
of these methods work to translate
invisible shifts in light phase that can
happen when studying certain samples
into visible changes in light amplitude
which we see as changes in light
intensity and as a result both
techniques enhance contrast and let us
see parts of the microcosmos that might
be invisible with regular bright field
microscopy but phase contrast microscopy
and dic
shift and work with light in different
ways to accomplish this goal
how do they do it
well if you've ever taken an optics
course
you will remember how terrible that was
but very basically phase contrast and
dic are two ways to take advantage of a
strange reality
light actually travels further through
some materials than others
kinda the optical path length is a
function of both the distance between
two points and the refractive index of
the material the light is traveling
through basically
denser samples have longer optical path
lengths
phase contrast microscopy takes
advantage of that making areas with
longer optical path lengths look darker
dic on the other hand doesn't make areas
that are denser darker it uses some very
cool optics to create sharp contrast in
areas of rapid
change in the optical path length
so the faster the gradient from more to
less dense or vice versa the more
contrast you see
but it's also important to note that
while these images are the result of
light traveling through a sample they
are not an actual topographical map of
an organism
dic microscopy is a technique but it
does require certain physical additions
to a microscope for one thing we need to
split light apart so first we have a
prism that splits polarized light into
two orthogonal rays of light that will
then
pass through the sample and interact
with it in different ways and then
there's a second prism that recombines
those two rays after they've traveled
through the sample forming an image
based on the differences those two beams
of light experienced for our eyes and
cameras to see
in addition to these prisms this
technique relies on having higher
quality objectives than what we've been
using in the past the objectives are the
little lenses at the bottom of the
microscope that actually do most of the
magnification
not many people would realize this but
the objectives we use for journey to the
micro cosmos are some of the cheapest
and most common types of objectives
they're known as achromatic objectives
but while these objectives produce so
many of our favorite images
james needed a microscope update to be
able to do differential interference
contrast so
with help perhaps including some from
you
james bought a new zeiss microscope it
took eight weeks for it to arrive which
is a long time to wait
but luckily the manufacturers sent him a
150 page manual to occupy his time until
it arrived
when the microscope finally showed up
james still had to wait for an engineer
to install the nearly 50-pound machine
but he didn't waste any time
james went out to gather his precious
melamonis and prepare to slide that
night keeping it stored in a humidity
chamber so that he could look at it as
soon as the microscope was ready the
next day the zeiss engineer took three
and a half hours to put all the pieces
together and set everything up but from
there
well it was all on james to observe what
he could and experiment with his new
microscope
some of his experimenting has been
geared towards making sure that he can
get the best image possible these
objectives have a much smaller working
distance compared to our previous ones
and so you need to prepare the slides a
lot thinner to get a sharper image so
even for our master of microscopes there
was somewhat of a learning curve to make
sure he was getting videos that were as
sharp and vivid as he wanted
but some of the experimenting is based
out of that most exciting thing of all
curiosity he's removed some of the
prisms to see how it affects the footage
and added a magnifying glass over the
light source to scatter the light in
different ways
that's the joy of the micro cosmos
it is so infinite there's its own
objective existence full of so many more
organisms than we'll ever be able to
identify
but there's also the infinite nature of
how we experience it of how our own view
of this world
is shaped by the many different tools we
use to observe it
and maybe that's the case all the time
that what we see is as much about how we
view the world as it is about the world
itself
the same thing
with a different lens a different
technique a different base of knowledge
can look completely different
as we start our third season of journey
to the micro cosmos we hope you will
continue to join us through both our new
and old lenses as we uncover more of
this hidden
unending world
now in 2021 james went all out on
improving his tool kit investing in a
higher quality objectives a polarizer
and even the equipment he needed to do
fluorescence microscopy now if you're
not sure why all of those things had
everyone on the journey to the micro
cosmos team so excited well that is what
our next video is for you will get to
see how much of a difference an
objective can make and why electrons
jumping up and down can reveal a whole
new side to the microcosmos
[Music]
we're nearing the end of our fourth
season of journey to the micro cosmos
and over that time we've been able to
see microbes through all kinds of lenses
literally thanks to james our master of
microscopes for the rest of us on the
micro cosmos team it's been really cool
to not only see the footage that james
has recorded but also see the journey
that he has been on with the microscopes
themselves
now we have been able to make this
journey because of all of you and the
support you have shown to this channel
by watching and commenting and sharing
with others or even and especially by
supporting us on patreon we've all been
on this journey together so let's look
back on where it's taken us and also get
a peek at where we're going in the
future
[Music]
in the first season james started out
with two microscopes one was a
microscope that he assembled himself
from different parts for under two
hundred dollars the other microscope was
a modic ba 310 that he received from a
microscope company shortly after we
started this channel
and these microscopes give us such
beautiful footage thanks in part to the
different techniques that james used
with them whether that was bright field
or phase contrast or dark field or some
other technique to manipulate the light
shining on the micro cosmos
but these microscopes also had their
limits so we were really excited to see
what would happen when james bought a
new microscope before the start of our
third season the zeiss axioscope 5. this
new microscope came with higher quality
objectives which are the lenses on the
bottom of the microscope as well as
prisms that made it possible for us to
look at microbes with differential
interference contrast microscopy a
technique that sharpened their features
and made them seem more
three-dimensional on our screen
we have videos exploring these different
techniques and microscopes so if you
want to learn more about them we
recommend checking those out because
light is much weirder than it seems but
we wanted to do a quick summary for
reasons that are probably very clear
from the title of this video we have
upgraded our microscope the zeiss
axioscope 5 was a very exciting change
but it was also an expensive one so when
james bought it he was only able to get
two objectives a 20 times objective and
a 63 times objective adding that to the
10 times magnification the eyepiece
gives let us magnify our samples by 200
times and 630 times respectively which
is not bad but a standard microscope
usually comes with five to six
objectives for a reason
the microcosmos is full of things both
small and large to observe and there is
not a one-size-fits-all objective that
you can use to observe everything so one
of james's priorities was expanding his
set of objectives so that he could have
the flexibility to see the micro cosmos
at more scales and thanks to his recent
upgrade he's now gone from a set of two
to a set of six that range from five
times to 100 times and that gives us a
magnification range from 50x to 1000x
since i've gotten my own prototype of
the microcosmos microscope that we are
manufacturing thanks to backers of our
kickstarter i have been amazed at how
important it is to have this variety of
options and how much time i spend on the
lower magnifications as well as going
deeper
so without further ado let's introduce
these different objectives by looking at
a ciliate called tetrahymena that's
taken up residence in a rotifer
exoskeleton
with the 5x objective we can see little
dots swimming and what used to be empty
space but it is hard to make out the
details here when we move to the 10x
objective we can start to make out
shapes of the tetrahymena and more of
the emptiness around them but it's
difficult to see the exoskeleton
then as we start to go up in
magnification the details of the
exoskeleton become clearer
it's cool to see more and more of these
details as we zoom in and especially
when we get to the 100 times objective
which gives us 1 000 times magnification
you can make out so much of the insides
of the tetrahymena that they look like
bags of
very resilient bubbles
[Music]
here's another cilia called a pseudo pro
radon that james looked at through all
of these objectives
at first it just looks like a little
green thing floating around and knocking
into stuff but as we go up in
magnification we can start to make up
the subtle undulations of its body which
shifts the different shades of green
and as we look even closer the green
itself takes on a new life revealing the
perimeters of the individual algae
inside the pseudoproradon
revealing those details inside the
tetrahymena and the pseudoproradon comes
at a cost we can't see as much of the
world around them whether that's the
emptiness around the road of her
exoskeleton or the objects that the
pseudoproradon keeps bumping into
whether or not you need those details
depends on what you are trying to learn
and what we are trying to show
and that's why having the flexibility to
look through a wider range of objectives
is such an exciting upgrade for us
objectives are our gateways into the
micro cosmos and we are excited to have
all of these new scales to look at
we've also made some other upgrades so
we can revisit techniques we used on
older microscopes like a polarizer
because who doesn't love this shiny
iridescent stuff
but we're not just sticking with what
we've known thanks to this upgrade we've
got a whole new way to look at cells
fluorescence microscopy and we are so
excited for this one
the techniques we've highlighted so far
are clever manipulations of white light
a mixture of many visible wavelengths of
light but in fluorescence microscopy
instead of illuminating our sample with
that mixture we choose a specific
wavelength of light that light is called
the excitation light because well it
excites certain structures based on
their chemistry and those excitable
structures then emit some light of their
own the emission light will then travel
back through the objective get past
barriers that filter out the excitation
light and then show up in our eyes as
vivid color
with our upgrade we have four different
wavelengths of light that we can use for
fluorescence microscopy and the parts of
the sample that we see fluoresce will
depend on which light we use
in this footage we're looking at the
pseudo proradon that we saw earlier only
this time it's being hit with 385
nanometer light the red we see is the
fluorescence from natural structures
this is called autofluorescence
the rest of the organism is dark because
it did not respond to that 385 nanometer
light making the color all the more
vibrant
but the power of fluorescence microscopy
is not just finding fluorescent
structures that exist in nature chemists
and biologists have developed all sorts
of ingenious techniques to highlight
different parts of cells using
fluorescent dyes and proteins
james is working on building up his
arsenal of fluorescence microscopy tools
and techniques so that soon we'll be
able to dive even deeper into the
microcosmos to seek out things that have
been hidden from us before uncovering
the unseen world
inside the unseen world that surrounds
us
[Music]
now the upgrades we've talked about in
the last few videos have involved fancy
equipment and exciting techniques but
light is so weird and powerful that
sometimes you don't need anything
particularly fancy to do something
useful sometimes you just need the right
objective and a little bit of oil
[Music]
if you've been following along with us
lately you probably know that we are
pretty excited about our latest
microscope upgrades and can you blame us
it's like having a new toy that is
actually a spaceship
it's pretty hard to shut up about
something that is shiny and new and also
takes you into a whole new world
and that's kind of what it feels like to
see our familiar friends at this
magnification even though we've seen
tardigrades many times before in so many
different ways we have not seen them
like this
[Music]
and bringing this level of magnification
gives us a new layer of the microcosmos
to explore it's like we've descended
into a new level of a cave getting
further from our world though
fortunately for the easily scared among
us the cave is metaphorical and the
risks are negligible all we need for the
journey are some objective lenses and a
tiny drop
of oil
yeah
oil
but to explain
what oil does we're gonna have to get a
little bit technical first because yes
we love our microbes but we're only able
to see them thanks to light
light is complicated but we need to give
it its do so let's start with the
objective lens
the main job of the objective lens is to
take light leaving the sample and focus
it into an image for us to see
and there are two main numbers that
describe an objective lens the first
one's pretty obvious it's the
magnification but the magnification you
see written on the objective lens is not
the same as the magnification we write
up in the corner of the videos that's
because the objective lens isn't the
only source of magnification in our
microscope we're also looking through an
eyepiece that has its own magnification
so the final magnification that we see
is the product of the objective lenses
and the eyepiece's magnifications now we
don't usually do math on this channel
but this is one of the rare cases where
the math and optics are straightforward
in our microscope the eyepiece has a
magnification of 10x so if we're looking
through a 63x objective the final
magnification is
630x and that is the number you'll see
in the corner
but you should never trust an optics
lesson that seems simple
how could it be when the image we're
seeing
is the product of so many things at once
some tangible like a lens others much
less so
and what is less tangible than light
which is as we've seen before on this
channel
a very strange thing
we cannot touch it but we can manipulate
it using what we know of the way it
travels and bends and reflects to see
our world differently but light
has its limits
the thing about making things larger is
that at some point it's not enough to
just zoom in you need to be able to
capture the detail that's there
and this leads us to the second
important number you will find on an
objective lens the numerical aperture
unlike magnification numerical aperture
is probably not super self-explanatory
what the number describes is the ability
of the objective to take in light
as light travels from the sample and to
the objective it radiates outward like a
cone
and the higher your numerical aperture
the wider the cone of light that's going
into your objective and that allows for
more rays to enter the objective from
all sorts of different angles helping to
illuminate more details and give greater
resolution to your final image but of
course not still not all that goes into
capturing the perfect microscopic image
[Music]
let's take a look at this glaucoma
spinning around at a thousand x
magnification it's visible and you can
see some of the details it looks fine
but let's take a look at it again here
same glaucoma same objective same level
of magnification what was fine before
now looks dull in comparison to the
image we were seeing before with the
detailed striations and vivid pockets of
green on the glaucoma's body to get from
one of these images to the other james
our master of microscopes didn't change
any of the technical settings on his
microscope or pull some kind of video
editing wizardry he just simply added a
drop of oil to the coverslip encasing
the glaucoma and then dipped the
objective into the oil
now this is because the cone of light
going from the specimen into the
objective isn't just going straight from
the sample to the lens it's passing
through something it's passing through
air
light travels at different speeds in
different materials and when it changes
from material to material it will bend
this is called refraction and materials
like oil slow light down more and that
matters to our microscope because it
gives us the wider cone of light that we
need to get a higher numerical aperture
whether we've got air between the sample
and the lens or oil when we're viewing
our samples depends on the objective
we're looking through our lower
magnification objectives have lower
numerical apertures and they're meant to
be used with air our higher
magnification objectives have higher
numerical apertures and they are meant
to be used with oil
using air with oil objectives gives us
poor images
and using oil with our dry objectives
would damage the objective so don't do
that the numerical aperture and its
relationship to resolution is important
because it puts a limit on just how much
magnification we can actually do with a
given objective there's a general
estimate if you're looking into
microscopy yourself that you'll get a
good magnification when you're working
in the range that's 500 to 1000 times
the numerical aperture of the objective
so our 100x objective and 1.3 numerical
aperture can reach a maximum of 1300x
magnification depending on your eyepiece
with our 10x eyepiece we get 1000x
magnification and it works great
but if we tried to get more from this
setup by increasing the magnification of
our eyepiece to 20x we could not
actually get 2000 x magnification
because of the constraints of our
numerical aperture we would just be
losing half of the image without
actually gaining more detail in what's
left to see
but that's what happens anytime we want
to take an image we have to make a
decision between what we can and cannot
see
there are always choices that have to be
made and details that have to be lost we
simply cannot see
all of the world in all its entirety all
at once but we can see more of it by
tracking the choices we make as we dive
deeper choices in techniques and
materials that affect what we can see
and how we see it and enrich the story
further even when those choices impose
constraints at some point in history
we wanted to see more and lenses with
their magnificent manipulation of light
have helped us do that we've used them
to see light from distant stars and to
peer into the most mundane surroundings
on earth and whatever image has come
back to us has brought the universe
closer to view even if it's just
infractions
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and remember if you're
watching this before august 8th you have
until then to check out our back to
school sale at microcosmos.store
almost everything in the store is 10 off
right now and we have a limited edition
dark mode hydra t-shirt that is only
available during the sale so check out
microcosmos.store before august 8th if
you want to get your hands on one
all the people whose names are coming up
on the screen right now they are our
patrons on patreon they are the reason
that we are able to continue exploring
this beautiful unseen world that
surrounds us there is so much left to
explore and i am so excited to continue
exploring it with you and with all of
our patrons and if you would like to
become one of these people you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss and why wouldn't you you can check
out jam and germs on instagram or on
tick tock and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you